Carl's jr. gearing up to test a CBD
infused burger at one of its Denver
locations it's hard to be pessimistic
about marijuana legalization these days
recreational cannabis is legal in ten
states and decriminalized in another
fourteen virtually all presidential
candidates including President Trump
favor letting states decide the legal
status of marijuana for the first time
polls show a majority of Republicans
supporting legalization and six
proposals to move marijuana in a more or
less libertarian direction are now
making their way through Congress what
do these policy proposals look like our
state's navigating the conflicts between
state and federal law and are there any
obstacles left on the path to nationwide
legalization i sat down with Eric
Altieri the executive director of normal
the National Organization for the Reform
of Marijuana Laws to talk about the
building momentum towards nationwide
legal pot so not to sound overly
optimistic about this but there are six
policy proposals floating through
Congress right now that seek to
transform Marijuana Policy in a really
positive direction I'm wondering what is
your take on all of them generally and
is there any one in particular one or
two in particular that strike view is
better than the others I think
unquestionably the momentum is on the
side of legalization supporters at this
point in history with ten states having
legalized adult use of marijuana 33
states with medical use programs and as
you mentioned a historic number of
proposals at the federal level that
would finally bring prohibition to an
end across this country it's it's really
exciting to see and and particularly
this year we've seen more action than
we've ever seen in that we've already
had our very first in history hearing on
a pro cannabis bill and that was the
marijuana banking bill that just moved
through committee and that was approved
and will likely be approved on the House
floor sometime soon and in addition to
that we're expecting that this year we
will finally have hearings and votes on
bills that would ultimately end
marijuana prohibition and they all
attempt to do it in slightly different
ways but from the house side it's
without a doubt the year that we're
gonna start seeing that that ball moved
forward we have several avenues which
that can proceed on one of the
poses that is out there and being
discussed as the states act which is
arguably the least ambitious of the
proposals this would simply create an
exemption in federal law that would
allow states who have changed their
policy to do so without federal
incursion it doesn't remove marijuana
from the Controlled Substances Act it
doesn't change anything in regards to
research availability it doesn't change
much in relation to banking or taxation
from marijuana businesses but the states
would at least not have fear that you
know federal boots on the ground are
something that could happen in the near
future for them next up the list is the
ending federal marijuana prohibition Act
which is a very clean bill it would
simply be scheduled marijuana entirely
out of the Controlled Substances Act
that would lead to fixing the issues of
manking and taxation that would help
lead to clearing up the issues of
research and the ability for people to
look into the benefits and potential
harms of the substance and really end a
federal prohibition nationwide much in
the way that alcohol prohibition was
ended it wouldn't immediately legalize
marijuana in every single state much
like ending federal alcohol prohibition
did not do that for alcohol but states
would be free to move forward and states
that chose to keep their prohibition
laws would be allowed to do so too and
then on the on the further more
ambitious and you have bills like the
marijuana Justice Act from Senator Cory
Booker and representative barbara Lee
this really looks to both be scheduled
marijuana but also begin to pursue
reparative justice for communities that
were most harmed by marijuana
prohibition so overwhelmingly as most
people know by now
marijuana prohibitions effects fall
disproportionately on communities of
color black and brown Americans are
arrested at four times our higher the
rate of white Americans despite using it
the same rates the over policing of
their communities has done untold damage
to them and this would look to refund
those communities with investments from
the taxation it would look to penalize
states that continued racial racist
applications and their arrests and begin
to have that very oriented discussion
around social and racial justice and
these are all very much in play and as
you can tell particularly from the
Democratic side of things this is where
the party is moving essentially every
single
a date that is running for president on
the Democratic side that is currently
serving in Congress is on one or all of
these bills from Bernie Sanders down to
Beto O'Rourke and everyone in between
they're all supporting ending federal
prohibition with the exception of Joe
Biden who's not quite in the race yet
but he's the he's the exception not the
rule here and we're beginning to see
that Republicans are also becoming much
more favorable tending marijuana
prohibition the states act that we just
talked about that was partially led by
Senator Cory Gardner a Republican from
Colorado the ending federal marijuana
prohibition Act in the house is
co-sponsored by Don Young the longest
serving Republican in Congress in the
house so it's slowly becoming a
bipartisan issue politically at the
elected level that we are seeing as well
at the public level where we finally see
over fifty percent of Republican voters
also support legalizing marijuana and
maybe just as important is some of the
institutional changes like proposed
banking legislation for example by and
large currently certainly all large
banking institutions are avoiding doing
business with any sort of marijuana
business and sometimes that's
individuals that are directly you know
touching the plant to people who are
only ancillary industries and that's
because they do fear because of this
state and federal law conflict they
could be charged with anything from from
RICO suits to you name it that would
jeopardize their broader business some
so they're very risk adverse when it
comes to marijuana we are seeing a few
local credit unions and things of that
sort starting to open their doors to
those businesses and it's really
important that we solve that because as
you noted that marijuana business is in
legal states now are essentially a
cash-only enterprise at the end of the
day they take there are thousands of
dollars and they stick it in a safe in
the back of the building when they need
to go you know pay their deposits or pay
their taxes they have to hire armored
vehicles some folks I talked to running
these businesses have to do different
routes every time that they map out to
make sure people aren't targeting them
for robbery it opens them up for
obviously all sorts of criminal elements
coming in to the business itself
attempting to rob them because they know
they're cash-heavy it also creates a
problem just from a you know a
regulatory standpoint where we don't
have a great idea of being able to track
this
the way we could with any other legal
enterprise we don't necessarily know how
it's coming in where it's going out that
they're keeping the books accordingly
because those are all this flaws
inherent in a cash-only business so that
is something that ultimately really
needs to be fixed
along with part parcel with that is the
taxation issue marijuana businesses
currently can't write off many business
expenses that any other business could
and because of the fact that they don't
have access to banking they're paying
most their taxes in cash and the IRS has
assesses a penalty if you pay your taxes
in cash so they're not allowed to pay
their taxes in cash and then they're
charged even more for that privilege of
paying in cash that they're forced into
anyway so it's really creating a lot of
problems for what is clearly becoming a
huge industry in this country the most
recent reports we have legal cannabis
employs more individuals than the coal
industry than the textile industry you
know there's hundreds of thousands of
Americans working in good-paying jobs
related to cannabis right now and we
need to really support those businesses
so we can see the economic benefits
instead of treating them like they're
still some criminal enterprise tell me
about the new Attorney General there's
certainly no sadness amongst the
marijuana community to see our former
beleaguered attorney general Jefferson
Beauregard sessions go he clearly had
nothing but disdain for marijuana and
any reforms to the law Colorado was one
of the leading states that started the
movement to suggest that marijuana is
not dangerous and we're going to find it
in my opinion ripple throughout the
entire American citizenry and we're
gonna see more marijuana use and it's
not going to be good fortunately for us
his bark was always worse than his bite
in practice he never got to really
implement any crackdown that he always
hinted he wanted so now we have Attorney
General bar for the time being and he
seems to be a bit more pragmatic on the
issue out of time we'll certainly tell
but just recently he was asked about it
in his hearings in front of Congress
this week and he said that he would love
to see something like the state's Act or
one of these other bills move forward to
clean up this tension we either should
have one
federal law that prohibits marijuana
everywhere which I would support myself
because I think it's a mistake to back
off on marijuana however if we want a
federal approach if we want States to
have their own laws and let's get there
and let's get there the right way
ultimately whether you believe them or
not
attorney generals are tasked with
enforcing the law as it's written and
what if you remove the issue of the law
and you say that these states are
allowed to move forward with these new
policies I think someone like Barr would
go along with that and would listen to
both the law and the will of the
overwhelming majority of Americans and
keep a hands-off policy but to be clear
he is a drug warrior right he is a drug
warrior as we saw during his time with
former President Bush he was very much a
just say no type let's amp up
prosecutions let's arrest people for
possession but you know like many others
you know as we've seen with people like
John Boehner and others uh time seems to
change people and they're not immune to
the climate around marijuana policy in
this country I think they they know
where the American people are moving on
this they see where state policies are
going and it's really rare to see
someone like a Jeff Sessions that's
still really willing to plant their flag
and die on this hill particularly when
the president wasn't supportive of that
policy in particular yes Donald Trump's
a bit of an enigma on this he said all
kinds of very surprising uh like most
issues he says all kinds of different
things on it ultimately we feel he he
just doesn't really care he doesn't seem
to prioritize this issue one way or
another on the campaign trail he said he
saw it as a states rights issue he
particularly was supportive of the idea
of medical marijuana we did get mixed
messages when he's appointing people
like Jeff Sessions but so far the Trump
administration well they haven't done
anything super damaging they haven't
done anything progressive on this either
he's selling the wall now more than ever
before as an anti-drug measure what's
going on with that ah you know that's
always been part of it that's why the
wall has to be see-through right because
they they throw the big bags of drugs
over the wall and you might hit the
Border Patrol on the head
there's always that risk because
obviously the border and drug
importation illicit drug importation has
always been kind of intertwined both to
a degree factually and to a degree I'm
in the public consciousness and as he
ramps up that rhetoric there's always
that risk that you know when he's
throwing in all these drug dealers
coming across the border that kind of
brings back some of that Anslinger esque
fear of immigrants coming from south of
the border with their marijuana trying
to corrupt American society so it could
go that far and he's definitely been
hinting at that in the way he discusses
as well also though on the other hand
you had folks like Steve Bannon I don't
know if you've seen this several months
ago hosted a press conference where the
law would go and suggested they build
the wall out of hempcrete which was a
very weird and surreal press conference
but I think it's it's you know it's
possible that they kind of hold both
views at the same time what kind of
substance is this that we're making the
wall out of in the battery you can make
concrete out of the hemp plant basically
by processing it and it creates a form
of you know concrete they're really
pretty renewable and resources so you
could smoke as well you I think that
might be a problem you know maybe
they'll just smoke through the wall but
that's you know it's as it's emblematic
of the Trump Republican mindset where I
think a lot of them have these anti-drug
views but so far I've seen to leave
marijuana out of it we do run the risk
as we get into 2020 and we've seen when
when threatened Donald Trump seems to
only amped his rhetoric up further that
if he sees that as a politically viable
Avenue he may go that way
but looking at public opinion polls I
think it's also just as likely he sees
and all his advisers see that doing any
sort of crackdown on legal marijuana in
this country would really only be to his
political detriment especially with
those independent voters who you know 60
to 65 percent support legalization and
we've seen less fewer less drugs or less
marijuana is it coming across the border
and is that some people attribute that
to our legalization policies is that
true yes are we generally have seen less
marijuana coming across the border
particularly when it comes to states
that have allowed legal or medical use
that are right on the border place like
Arizona and
California you know and quite frankly
America now grows the best marijuana in
the world our technology has gotten to
the point where we if you're a
connoisseur is looking for quality
cannabis you want American grown
cannabis right on and that doesn't quite
meet the standards of that stereotypical
brick weed that we've associated is
coming from south of the border for a
while so they've you know like any
market they have intense competition now
if you're in Oregon for instance where
you could buy an ounce of marijuana
high-quality for for forty dollars do
you want to go on the illicit market and
buy an ounce for $200 of dubious quality
you don't know if it was tested for
pesticides you don't know anything about
it
American consumers generally want to
know what's in their product and that
it's a quality product that's safe and
they want to be affordable and as long
as we can make sure the legal marijuana
market meets those things the black
market will continue to diminish in this
country it's just one bit of good news
after another is there anything to be
pessimistic about I don't think so I
mean I think that there's a lot of
things we need to continue to consider
and learn as we move forward because now
we have these laboratories of democracy
you know ten of them that are moving
forward illegal marijuana markets what
works what doesn't work you know I think
that generally we should be cautious of
only having limited number of licenses
that are large-scale licenses and
opening it up to giant corporations
necessarily who are less caring about
the communities they're gonna be working
in and that have nothing but profit
incentive we should spread out I think
that generally those licenses so one
people who were suffering under the drug
war have the ability to get into the
market and have mom-and-pop shops
small-scale marijuana grows and
businesses we want to make sure that the
tax rates are set properly not too high
to continue to let the black market
thrive and you know not necessarily too
low to you know put the profits
completely in the dust and no one wants
to partake in the market so there's a
lot of things to consider as move
forward and I think you know all this
talk about you know marnark minority
inclusion in the industry is an
important discussion to have that a lot
of states are having and also that most
legalization now should come with things
like expungement so if you are carrying
a criminal record
for something that is now state legal we
should take that burden off you so you
should no longer have to deal with them
does your organization see that as the
biggest challenge moving forward that
the regulation of the marijuana industry
could end up being too heavy-handed and
the black market will therefore still
have a big place because it's not
competitive with the black market
it goes both ways and it's about finding
that happy medium mom you know you don't
be too heavy-handed but you don't to be
necessarily the most open regulations in
the world because you have things like
again you know some states where they
gave out too many licenses places are
sitting on stockpiles of marijuana they
can't feasibly sell but a lot of that
comes back to that we're still in this
very strange state-by-state system if
you grow marijuana and Oregon you have
to sell it in Oregon you can't ship that
to California you can't ship that to
other states which isn't how most
industry works in this country you have
you have areas that are producer regions
and you have areas that are more
consumer Reed because of laws against
interstate commerce that's federal
yes federal laws against interstate
commerce so currently there is no
commerce between the states whatsoever
so you can ship it between the states if
you have access if you have a certain
product you're making an organ that
somebody wants in Massachusetts you you
can't simply sell it to distributors
there and obviously that feeds into
international commerce now that we have
Canada has a legal marijuana market
north of our border Mexico is slowly
moving towards legalization itself and
by restricting these markets we've we've
created a lot of interesting problems
that ultimately if there was a
nationwide legalization structure where
most states had it and we could have
that kind of interactivity in the
markets what exists how are we doing in
DC we seem to be in a weird spot where
both federal district and local at the
same time what's going on here
DC obviously is an incredibly unique
situation and we're not a state we don't
we have some autonomy but not a lot of
it Congress has the ultimate say on our
appropriations and our budget and since
we legalize marijuana in 2014 with
initiative 71 which legalized possession
and home cultivation we haven't been
able to move forward on on the retail
aspect despite that you know the City
Council wants to the mayor wants to the
people certainly want to and that's
because representative Andy Harris from
the Eastern Shore of Maryland
can very conservative member of Congress
every year puts a rider on the DC
appropriations bill that says DC can
expend no funds to regulate the sale or
consumption of marijuana essentially
blocking us from ever moving forward on
it even if we wanted to the good news on
that front is and now that the
Democratic Party is taken back the house
side which is the one that oversees the
appropriation bills at their inception
it's very unlikely that that will be
included this time in fact most of the
members of the committee have told us
that they're going to fight to keep that
out and make sure that stays out as
we've seen with her reelection on mayor
Bowser as said she's more than ready to
move forward on this and once - as soon
as she can so I think in the next
several years we'll see that you know
prohibition on sales in DC go away and
the DC Council will rather expeditiously
move to set up a retail market in
Washington DC so Kamala Harris giveth
Andy Harris taketh away yes well thanks
for talking to us Eric I appreciate very
much revenue Eric Altieri the executive
director of normal I'm Todd Crain and
for reason
[Music]